- Hey vlog, did you capture that footage?
Whenever you cut capture, just run it.
Vlog, I just tore my ACL I think.
(hip hop)
So, but yeah it's the fifth book.
I'm excited about it.
Crush It was the biggest book I wrote.
The first one, so this
is the follow up to it.
- After the wine book.
- Yeah, exactly.
This is the follow up to it,
and it's just super relvant,
it's basically like the first several,
the first kind of part of it,
part one is like, just complete mindset,
like fuck man, like do you understand
that if you have $413,000 in college debt,
come from alcoholic parents,
and work at Saks Fifth Avenue,
that's still, at 7:30 when
you get home from your
fuckin' hour and a half commute,
still you can take your fuckin' phone out
and do damage for five hours,
and over the course of six years,
turn around that ridiculously
impossible narrative
that you're stuck in,
the fact that that's
true is batshit crazy.
- Yeah.
- When I wrote the first one,
people were like, what? Go on YouTube?
Make a living? Wait, what?
Be the king of honey?
And make 90,000 a year
instead of making 72?
I think you and I are anomalies.
I do not think that somebody
in Cincinnati right now
who makes 47k, working retail,
can't make 51 being the
biggest expert on Star Trek.
I don't think people
understand the long tail.
- Sure.
- That's a big fuckin' deal.
The variable difference of happiness of
making 81k in upper
management and something
that makes you miserable,
versus making 64, talking
about whiffle ball all day,
is a big deal.
To me, it's just about happiness.
And I just think that a lot of people
don't realize how much they
know about a very narrow niche
that also has a ton of other
people that are into it,
and if they understand
how to use Instagram,
YouTube, Facebook and podcasting,
they just can't understand
how much money there is.
Heading upstairs to a meeting,
it's always fun when you have a client or
potential client within your own building.
- I think I need to kind of figure out --
- What?
- That the world I wanna
go into is so huge,
and it's getting really cluttered,
and it's getting really inauthentic.
- Can I give you a quick piece of advice?
- Please.
- Every world is like that.
- Yeah.
- Don't let that cripple you.
- And go narrow to what makes you pop.
- Right.
- Motivational speakers
are my most hated people.
- You mean by other people?
- I hate them.
Yet, I get categorized in
that world all the time.
- Right.
- But I'm not crippled
because I know that I'm not
trying to do the wrong thing.
- Right. Or you're not
trying to do whatever --
- The wrong thing.
Forget about that.
- Yeah.
- Don't ever look for the
white space that doesn't exist.
- Mm hmm, yeah. Just like make it --
- Do what the fuck you know --
if you know yoga, yoga's
plenty fuckin', ya know?
- Yeah.
- Be in "the cream rises
to the top" business,
not in the "I'm gonna see
something nobody else sees"
business.
So all the people that
are doing the wrong thing,
crowded, not authentic, it just
has nothing to do with you.
I'm not crippled by
other agencies sucking at
giving a fuck about people.
- Yeah, if you were, you
wouldn't be where you are.
- That's the thing you need to do.
- A lot of people are like,
"You know, what you're doing
it's kind of risky," and like --
- Risky for what?
- I dunno, I just don't
believe in this whole notion of
like, okay you graduate, then you work --
- You can come back and
work here, the same spot.
- Yeah, I also just don't --
- I actually think the other way is risky.
- Me too because I think it's really easy
to become complacent.
- 100%.
- And I don't, I dunno.
I don't think it's deviating from a path,
because I don't think
that there is a path.
- There's way too much respect for
anybody who thinks what
you're doing is risky.
- Yeah, I mean I've literally
gotten that response from
one person, but my family is like,
yes, 100%, go, they're so --
- And the person that's saying that
respects a certain narrative
and that's awesome too.
- Right, and that's great for them.
- It may be great for
them forever. Yeah, maybe.
Going with Ryan Harwood
right here, CEO of PureWow.
Very smart and handsome.
Going to see a potential
client for PureWow.
VaynerX baby.
- Let's rock it.
- Alex, I'm sending an
email to the company asking
who's an Eagles fan.
And they're gonna email you
that they're an Eagle's fan,
put it in a folder, okay?
- [Woman] Maggie Huggins
is an Eagle's fan.
- That's the best email.
If you're a real Philadelphia Eagle's fan,
and work at VaynerMedia,
please email Alexandria
that you are.
Please email Alexandria ASAP.
She's CC'd here, in the body, don't lie.
(laughs)
Sent.
- [Woman] Sent.
- I love everbody be like
"What about Patriot fans?"
I'm not sending any fucking
Patriot fans to Superbowl.
But four Eagle fans from
VaynerMedia are going.
Andy, are you placing some ads?
Gettin' back to your
roots and doing somethin'?
- Get me a copy, an IG copy for the
Crushing It video?
Signing.
- I don't even know what I'm doing,
I'm like "what is this machine?"
(laughs)
Known as the computer.
My guy.
How you doin' man?
I've been lookin' forward to this man.
I've been lookin' forward to it.
What's up man.
- Number one in LA --
- I fuck with you heavy as fuck.
I think you guys know,
I'm putting you on blast.
I'm on the record of who I
think is next, and it's you.
Because I have that like, I know my ear,
which is like, I don't think I'm anything,
I don't even like to talk
to music people about music,
but I know me, and I
know like, I just know.
Honestly, on a very serious note man,
I really, really, really
think you've got the
absolute exact right thing
for what's about to happen.
I just think you need to,
you know my big thing is
collaborations and volume.
You guys do you, that's always my thing.
To me, I just want you to do more shit,
it's always tricky with
my advice to artists,
'cause I want more volume,
and artists can run like,
they don't wanna dilute it,
they want it to be like per --
I have empathy.
But I know it's right,
here's what people don't
understand with volume.
They remember the hits,
they forget the other shit.
You don't have the potential to suck.
You understand that, right?
If I was like --
but, do you understand what I mean?
If I was like, yo, you have
to put out a hundred songs
in a row, your weakest
one of those hundred,
in my opinion, isn't gonna be
weak enough to fuck you up.
And the upside of a
hundred fuckin' at bats,
I believe in that shit.
And then collaborations like,
fuck, I think I was just listening
to one of yours just now,
let me see.
This would be great.
Yup, this is literally
what I'm listening to.
(♪ "Monday to Monday" by SABA)
Like this, as many of those as possible.
I can't say it enough man,
you guys are in it, and
you know it better than me,
I just know what humans do.
That's why I'm gonna do my thing,
it's just at bats.
People don't get it.
It's just tomorrow's song,
that changes everything.
- I think people would wanna know,
all this music is so personal
and it's so motivational,
- That's why I like it.
- That's why you like it.
Everyone likes it.
- I like Russ because
he's competitive and chip on the shoulder.
It's all based on versions
of my own personality.
- It's so smooth and then it's like,
you perform that to a live
ass crowd and it's a smash.
- You're talkin' truth.
- He's real.
- And you're not scared to
go into territories that
don't look the part.
That's it.
- I be speakin' like third person,
I got a song called "Money Don't Change"
on CD three,
"I hope the money don't change you,"
and I ain't talkin' to like,
nobody else but myself.
- You know what's funny about that?
One of my favorite things I say ever,
I say a lotta shit,
is "money doesn't change
you, it just exposes you."
I'm not a real music guy,
the reason I fuck with
you is what you're saying.
I like the story, ya know?
I like that you're going
to places that I think
are vulnerable and truth,
'cause that guy and that
girl will always win.
That's what people don't
understand about Pac and Biggie,
actually go back and
listen to Pac and Biggie.
- Real life stuff.
- You guys are youngsters,
you don't understand,
Brenda's got a baby, that was ridiculous.
That was shit like, like Biggie --
- [Gunna] It made people cry,
it brought tears to people's eyes.
- And just like story telling, right?
Biggie's funny, like I got a
story to tell you, it's funny.
That was different.
This was when hip hop was like,
I'm hardcore, I'm tough
and you're not, simple.
Binary. There was no other story.
They broke out for a million reasons,
I mean I watch every documentary,
I read everything,
and I'm waiting for somebody to say,
those guys broke out.
They say storytellers,
they'll compare them to KRS
One and things, that's fine.
It's the vulnerability.
My advice, go in a cocoon.
Meaning go out, but
like mentally, a cocoon.
Anything that veers you from
completely dominating, be out.
You can go out every night,
but don't get caught up in anything,
like you need to be obsessed.
'Cause gifts are fuckin' rare, man.
My guy.
- Thanks.
- Yeah, man, I'm really rootin' for you.
Good to see you.
(laughs)
Real pleasure man.
Good to see you, bro.
Don't ever wear that jersey in here again.
(laughs)
Come on, let's go.
I love it.
Thank you.
See ya.
- [Woman] Are you okay?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Woman] You sure?
- [Woman] Going? Oh my god. I feel so --
- Hey vlog, didn't capture that footage?
Whenever you cut capture, just run it.
Vlog, I just tore my ACL I think.
The elevator just destroyed my knee.
But that's what you have to
do when you fuckin' hustle.
Stick your leg in the elevator
to save that 28 seconds in my count.
(techno music)